Justine - Hello!
Oh boy!
Today is the day that
the iPad Pro is released.
I'm actually in New York right now,
I have no idea what this video looks like
because I forgot my little monitor
so the only way that I
can kind of see you guys
is there's a mirror, but you're,
so I have to go like this to
see in the mirror to see you.
It's really quite silly.
But I wasn't home to be able
to get my iPad that I ordered,
and it's great that I wasn't home
because I actually forgot to pre-order.
I ordered an engraved pen,
I ordered the Folio Pad,
I ordered a case, I ordered
everything except the iPad
because what I thought I had
done is ordered the iPad first
but then I got side-tracked
by engraving my pen
and tweeting and a lot
of different things.
But I'm here, I'm in New York,
and I got a chance to see the
temporary 5th Avenue Apple store,
and I feel like that 5th
Avenue store has been
under construction for a really long time.
So anyway, I went in
today, got some goodies.
Pretty hyped about it.
Can I even see myself?
Is this over-exposed?
Who knows.
I'm actually in New York to
go to Good Morning America.
Be sure to look for me
on the show if you watch,
or if your mom watches,
or if you have family that watches,
tell them that you know me.
Tell them that we're friends,
if you need me to send a tweet
to say that were friends,
to confirm it, tweet me,
I will do that for you.
Pencil.
What did I call, did I
call it a pen earlier?
I'm not sure, I'm delirious.
I honestly don't know when
the last time was I slept.
I think the last time I
slept was when (mumbles).
That was a long time ago.
iPad Pro.
Smart Keyboard Folio!
We've also got some dongles
because something that's pretty
exciting about the iPad Pro
is it does feature USBCs,
so with USBCs you can
do so many more things
than you could previously with Lightning.
So you can actually use your
iPad Pro to charge your iPhone.
I need to take my shoes
off, I gotta get comfy.
This is a real chill unboxing
and I hope that you enjoy it.
I hope I'm even recording,
I don't even know.
So this does feature USBC,
you can also use an external monitor.
Probably should not have
returned mine and just kept it
because it's times like these.
(fuzzy music)
♪ It's times like these, ♪
♪ You learn to love again. ♪
Oh man I love the Foo Fighters.
Where was I (laughs)?
We're going to un-box now, I promise you.
If you can make it to
the end of this video,
congratulations.
I mentioned this in my iPad Air video
but just in case you missed that video,
be sure to go check it out.
Jonathan and I are doing another giveaway
of either an iPad Pro or a MacBook Air,
whichever one you guys want.
In addition to our iPhone 10r giveaway.
So we're gonna be announcing
those winners at the same time,
so if you wanna go check it out,
check out Jonathon's channel,
check out my channel,
subscribe to both, like our videos
and we'll be choosing the
winners very, very shortly.
Here's the problem with traveling:
I don't have a knife.
I didn't check a bag so I
couldn't travel with a knife.
So this is knife-less un-boxing,
hope that you understand.
I hope that this is even in focus.
This could very well be in
manual focus for all I know.
This could be the worst
thing that I've ever done.
No, that's not true,
cause' I've posted a lot
of crap on the Internet.
If you guys aren't already
subscribed to my channel
please do so
because I'm working on a
really fun iPad Pro video.
This is just the unboxing,
but I really want to
test out the capabilities
for actual artists and creators
because I don't really
use this for illustration
but I have a friend who does,
so he is going to be creating
a really cool illustration for you
and showing you guys how
a real creative artist
actually uses an iPad, other than me,
who watches Netflix and workout videos
and spills Doritos all over it (laughs).
This thing looks so good,
I saw it at the Apple store
and it's always so cool
going into Apple stores
because sometimes, a lot of you guys,
you don't really know what
to say when you see me there,
or you don't think it's actually me
so then you ask questions like,
'hey so do you make Youtube videos?',
I'm like 'yes, I am,
give me a freakin' hug!'
Get a good look at this.
(plastic tearing)
You look
great.
So this is the one terabyte version,
which is absolutely absurd.
What am I gonna do with
a one terabyte iPad?
I'm asking myself the same question.
It smells like a vanilla-spiced
latte with a hint
of cinnamon, wow are you delicious!
So there's the camera
and if you are completely new here
and haven't seen any videos
about the iPad Pro yet,
this is the 12.9 inch model.
This is the one terabyte version,
they also have one with cellular and wifi.
I usually end up just
doing things off of wifi
or tethering with my phone,
so this is the wifi model,
one terabyte of delicious,
delicious storage.
This features the new A12 X Bionic Chip.
There's no home button so
it now does feature face ID.
So this really is, kind of just like,
a really massive iPhone
and the screen looks so good!
Quick start, so if an iPhone or iPad
running iOS 11 or later,
bring it nearby, alright.
Set me up, baby!
The new Apple Pencil now
features gesture controls
so if you are an illustrator
or somebody who does
those kinds of things,
I think this will be super helpful
because you can switch
through brush strokes
and different things and
you don't actually have to
go into menu settings or anything!
You just, double tap.
Okay let's set this up
to the hotel I'm in,
this hotel is incredible, by the way,
the lighting is not ideal for shooting
but everything else is amazing.
Give me my complimentary wifi please.
So it's saying that it might take
a few moments to activate my iPad.
Don't worry, I have all
the moments that you need
so take your time.
I don't actually have that many moments
because I'm hungry and
I wanna go get dinner
so don't take too much time.
Face ID, I'm setting up face
ID on this massive tablet!
How am I, this is so huge!
I can't even imagine what people
next door might think that
is happening in here.
I'm just unboxing an iPad
if someone can hear me,
don't be concerned.
Okay, you set up my Apple ID,
I'm going to show them something else,
so I'm talking to my
iPad like it's a person.
Are you surprised?
What else do we have in the box?
We've got,
wowee!
So, well I was trying to
act surprised but I'm not
really good at faking my emotion.
These stickers I actually
saw Jonathon un-box
and he made note of how
massive these stickers are.
They are much larger, I feel like,
than the previous versions,
I don't have any with me, to compare.
So we've also got a USBC cable and, oh!
Look at this.
This looks like all of the charging bricks
that come with all of
the Google accessories,
but this is an all new charging brick,
I've never seen one of
these from Apple before.
It's so dark in here, or I'm old,
but I can't read the voltage on it so,
uh, shit, we into the retirement home.
How am I supposed to
comfortably show you this?
This is so ridiculous
and I'm loving every
freakin' second of it!
Brightness is turned up.
So I guess I should, I
don't know what to do now.
I should probably download Procreate.
So let's see what else we have.
So this is their new keyboard.
This is something that I
would need my knife for.
But I don't have one.
Do you know how many knives
I've had taken away from me
at TSA?
Probably like 14.
I even had my tactical
knives taken, like come on,
let me take that through.
I'm not gonna do anything (sighs).
So I ended up getting the Space Gray one.
Everyone was joking, their like,
well Justine, how are you going to survive
without not having a gold iPad?
I don't know how I'm going to survive
but I think I'll be okay.
Look at you, oh!
Fancy, hello!
Anything else in here?
So it has a little magnetic
little docking station here,
so that's actually how it stays put
and then it has two
different settings here.
So there's one.
If it's on your desk, and here is two,
that is really in there.
That's good, that's nice!
And this second little
setting, if its on your lap.
Well, I think I'm way more into this iPad
than I thought I was gonna be.
Oh, now I'm like hyped for my flight back.
I'm just going to be sitting
there like can somebody please
talk to me about my new iPad?
Does anyone wanna talk about it?
Cause' it's here, can we chat?
Do you wanna be my friend?
Here's a little test.
Can you see?
Hello, I am typing (laughs).
This feels nice, oh wow!
I like it.
It's a nice feel.
Yeah, I'm into that.
That's a nice type,
that's a very nice type.
(typing)
Gosh, maybe I'll respond to my emails now.
It's now onto the pencil.
This is the Apple Pencil two,
this features gesture control
and you can now magnetically
attach it to your iPad.
I don't know if you guys
remember, well (sighs),
if you have an iPad and
you have an Apple Pencil
and you charge it, there's no
way that you'll ever forget
how you had to freakin'
charge that thing, like
you would just jam it into the
lightning cable at the bottom
then you would have this pencil
sticking out of your iPad
and it looked absolutely ridiculous.
I don't know what they were
thinking, I honestly am not sure
for whatever reason.
It still worked and the
Apple Pencil is incredible
and I think it's such a cool device.
We love the pencil,
we've got some paperwork.
Wouldn't that be great
if they had little, mini
stickers in here, I know
it would be a surprise,
I'd be shocked.
I also got one of these and
I got my name engraved in it.
I don't know why, it said, 'do
you want the free engraving'
and I said yes.
Here we go.
Oh, there's still something on this.
(crinkling)
Okay (laughs).
Now, witness my friends.
We even had, oh wow that was great.
Look, look what it's doin'!
Look, it's doing something!
Apple Pencil, connect,
yes I wanna to connect it!
No way!
I'm actually left-handed, so.
Whatever.
So I'm an artist, as you can see,
this is what I like to call:
mistakes were made.
(laughing)
So if you like, prints will be available,
I'll put a link in the
descrip- I'm just kidding.
I'm not actually, actually I
probably should print this out
because it is the best
thing I've ever seen.
Mistakes were made.
You probably can't see
it, I can't even see it.
Is this video even recording
(laughs), I don't know!
Let's put that there.
God this pencil (sighs),
this iPad's really beautiful.
This is a USBC to SD card
reader, so because this is USBC,
you now can use USBC dongles,
so accessories, like this,
and I'm also excited about this.
Why did it take Apple so long
to make a USBC SD card reader?
(scoffs) I don't know!
But it doesn't matter, they have one now.
So you can use this to transfer
footage to your iPad pro.
This is one of the
Thunderbolt three USBC cables
so this will be able to
transfer data much quicker
and then what is this for?
This is the USBC digital
AV Multi-Port Adapter.
So this will allow you to
have an addition USBC port
and HDMI and just a regular USB port,
so this is actually quite nice
and I'm kind of excited
because I can use these
with my MacBook Pro,
cause' I will never say
no to a USBC dongle.
(gasps) look at this!
I freakin' love technology.
I love the future,
where we are right now is
such an incredible time
because I feel like we are on the verge
of so many incredible things in the next,
I was going to say the
next five-ten years,
but even in the next year.
Car tech, AR, VR, so many amazing things.
If you guys stay subscribed to my channel
you may get to see some of it.
Oh I also went into the Lego store today.
I bought myself a New York luggage tag,
just this Lego New York, uh, body,
cause' I didn't really need anything else,
just thought I'd bring this back home,
to put on my Lego mini figures.
Don't ask.
So now with face ID on the
brand new iPad, the iPhone,
that just leaves the MacBook and the iMacs
to also start integrating face ID.
So that's going to be pretty cool.
It's kind of interesting
that they haven't really
done that already, I mean
it's not that shocking
because it probably would
increase the price of those
machines, as is.
I'm so excited to shoot my
more in-depth video with this.
It's gonna be really cool
and I'm so excited to share with you
from someone else's perspective,
on what it's like to use an iPad
and also I want to do some AR demos,
so there's so many other things
that I would love to do with this,
so if you guys have any other suggestions
on things that you might like to see,
leave those in the comments below
and I will see you very,
very, very, very soon.
Probably in like, a few days,
cause' I have to shoot and edit the video
but if you happen to be watching
Good Morning America tomorrow
I'll see you there!
Bye!
(calm, ambient music)